foreign
[Music]
was visiting last week and stayed at my
house yesterday we went out for a few
hours and I wore heels and encouraged
her to wear a cute pair of heels as well
by the time we got back our feet were in
a lot of pain my boyfriend gave me a
foot massage as he always does whenever
my feet hurt and my friend asks him for
one as well but I didn't feel
comfortable with that and asked him not
to my friend got upset she said that I
was an a-hole for leaving her in pain
and that I was the one who gave her the
idea to wear heels for that long but I
just didn't feel comfortable with my
boyfriend giving another woman a foot
rub am I the a-hole
well you are the a-hole only for taking
your nasty feet out and asking for a
foot rub and full view of another person
you've been walking around all day
in heels and then you pull your feet out
you can take your sock off I guess we
weren't probably wearing socks if
weren't heels and you're showing those
off in front of somebody else feet are
disgusting should never be seen by
anybody other than your podiatrist oh
suck it what
don't worry your friend is even worse
she not only wanted to take her feet out
but actually was soliciting someone
else's boyfriend to rub them what kind
of freak are you hanging out with the
foot massage is nothing I give my mother
it's bad enough that you asked your
boyfriend to rub your feet did you mean
wash your feet first
you take a shower first before you made
this request
but for her it's even more perverse and
and her reason is that she wore heels
well whose fault is that this is why you
know I don't like to hear this some of
these complaints from women about uh
it's so hard we have to wear heels and
makes our feet hurt what's your decision
high heels are a cross that women are
meant to bear with stoicism and dignity
[Music]
am I the a-hole for not allowing my
brother and his wife to stay over in our
family vacation house if they bring the
dogs don't need to read the story here
uh you are not you are not the a-hole
quite the opposite I'm gonna say this
because no one else will I'm not an
[ __ ] no one should try to bring their
mangy mutts into somebody else's house
it's bad enough to have them in your own
house but to bring him something that's
almost as bad as exposing your feet he
did tell you about defeat that's why I
also don't get back to the feet thing
for a second you know the people that
are like uh they want you to take your
shoes off in their house
that I we don't do that in our house why
first of all it's weird the the second
someone walks into your house
you're you're telling them to take off
items of clothing how far is this going
to go strip and and also I no I don't
want to see I don't even like you're
just coming in my house
I don't want to see your feet I don't
know where you've been this whole time
but anyway taking the shoes off that's
almost as bad as bringing the dog in and
but here's my question my question like
why do we give dogs special treatment in
general in life but when it comes to
this
like when it comes to pets if I had a
free-range tarantula that I let crawl
around my house and then I came to your
house and I said oh I brought my
tarantula hope you don't mind and I just
let it loose in your living room okay
you'd probably be upset about that
how is this different what if I wanted
to bring my kangaroo to your house or my
pet crocodile no you would say what are
you doing bringing animals into my house
I invited you over you're a human I
didn't invite any am this isn't a zoo I
don't make an exception for dogs I don't
don't be an initial
[Music]
I acknowledge as a father and husband
that a lot of things that were
singularly mine just before now aren't
the wife steals my clothes wife and kids
steal my food kids steal my phone
stealing the clothes thing is is that's
really a thing I mean all this is a
thing this is the stuff that wife and
kids do
the stealing closing that's when I
didn't quite expect ahead of time like
my wife and I are not the same size
thankfully and but she she like take my
sweatpants she'll take my you know my
slippers she's always stealing those
they don't fit her at all they're also
gross like why would you want to wear my
slippers have you seen my feet
speaking of feet enough
um anyway they uh steal all these things
and usually I'm fine with it but I just
needed one thing to myself without
hurting feelings and making someone cry
because everybody is sensitive in this
house including me I bought a single
serve piece of cake and ate it in my car
without any wife sneaking bits or kids
licking the chocolate from the top
unfortunately I got caught my wife is
upset with me for going so far as to eat
cake while hiding in my car and called
me dramatic when I told her my reasoning
am I the a-hole no
you're not remotely vehicle not at all
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you're cool
you as the man of the house have a right
to eat some damned cake every once in a
while without a bunch of piranhas
swarming you and and nibbling at it your
only mistake was eating the cake I guess
did you eat it in the car
in your own at your own house like in
your driveway you snuck out that's a
rookie move
you don't do that or or did she discover
the the packaging or something like that
no um what you do is you you go and you
get the cake or whatever snack you want
at the store the restaurant you eat it
in the parking lot and this is why in
any restaurant Park store parking lot
you look around
and but pretty much any parking lot any
time you're going to see men alone in
cars eating this is a thing that we do
it's the one place we get some peace and
quiet it's our sanctuary and uh so you
eat in the car and then you throw away
the evidence and then you drive home
I've been through this many times you
know I have snacks in my house that are
supposed to be just for me so I have to
hide them you can also do that but
that's a tough that could be a tough
move sometimes but you hide your snacks
like like sacred artifacts you hide them
away
for example I really enjoy fruit snacks
yes I like fruit snacks as a grown man
what of it
got something to say about that I do
like frozen snacks I like the Mott's
fruit snacks or Scooby-Doo don't bring
any of that Welsh's around me I don't
eat that but if I bring a box of fruit
snacks home
my kids will consume the entire thing
including the box within an hour
so I have to hide it I have to like
climb a mountain and bury it up there or
or descend into a cavern into a cave
like Gollum if anyone comes into the
cave and wants a fruit snack I have to
ask them three riddles you know it's a
whole thing it's weird anyway you're not
the ale uh not at all you do you do the
right thing you just you're incompetent
in this case you'll get better with time
uh for your own sake you have to holiday
season is rapidly approaching and if
there's one thing I love more than
spending the holidays with my family
it's spending the holidays with my
family while eating delicious meat from
good ranchers not only is good ranchers
meet Superior in quality but also it's
incredibly cost efficient as well while
grocery store meat prices are on the
rise good ranchers is dedicated to
helping you save as much as possible so
if you subscribe to good ranchers today
you can lock in your price and avoid
those insanely high prices at the
grocery store plus it's a special gift
for my listeners this holiday season
good ranchers is giving away two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order uh there are two 12-ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 dollar
value you get it for free you don't want
to miss out on that Black Angus tastes
better and is more tender than other
beef that's attributed to the meats
marbling and marbled meat the fat is
distributed thinly and evenly which is
why you get that consistent flavor plus
the Black Angus from good ranchers is
hand cut and trimmed by expert butchers
so you know every piece is going to be
Exquisite so go to goodranchers.com
Walsh use code walls to check out for
this special offer that's
goodranchors.com Walsh for two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order good ranchers American Meat
delivered
I'm the winner
[Music]
[Music]